neige froid polaire neige forte gelée le
cycle infernal continue et va continuer
après l'est - 24° au sol de cette nuit
nous allons connaître un petit mieux
cette nuit du côté des températures
puisque le thermomètre ne devrait
descendre que jusqu'à -10 à -15 degrés
en revanche c'est la neige qui revient
en force pour mercredi et jeudi
une neige et c'était c'est rare chez
nous qui va tomber par des températures
négatives environ - 4° comme maximum
pendant les deux prochains jours et -6
degrés la nuit
mais après le passage de cette
importante zone neigeuse le froid sera
plus vif pour la fin de la semaine
bref tous les inconvénients dus à cette
vague de froid vont se poursuivre
les canaux et les rivières commence à
être pris par les glaces
déjà cinq centimètres sur la sambre
entre pont sur sambre et berlaimont
[Musique]